hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play Kreischer custom campaign out
of it and no joke I'm out of it because
that last little bit there was confusing
as all hell
running towards legged door a hallway
just trippy
really weird a night I'm guessing this
is him tripping on acid really bad
okay
all right what duh what you gotta be you
got it ah you gotta be really really
yeah my game just either crashed or
something I don't know what's going on
but that's like the end of the I am so
confused I think my game into just
crashed or maybe my game bugged out
because I remember that happening before
hey let me just speed through this real
quick
wait no you can't even see I'm not
recording right so three two one and
Bing there's video oh you're that it's
like magic I just make video here I'm
like really really confused at this so
I'm gonna go through this again because
I have a feeling something bugged wait
no what what I haven't even gotten to
keep what I saved after oh oh no wait no
that's that's right that's right I was a
different one it was good the top one
cuz that's that's not confusing at all
so we're gonna go back we're gonna do
it's not far
so gonna go back and figure this [ __ ]
out because I am utterly confused
utterly cuz that can't be right
all right stash out gun hey buddy
where's your move
what the hell what your bone I said
what's up weird you son of a
[ __ ] everybody else want some
huh
too bad cuz I got a wooden plank ah boom
boom there we go okay now I get to do a
wooden plank hello buddy
excuse me while I do this real quick
then up up and over
okay now this thoroughly weird thing
we'll try it again
haha
okay so and then it says the end but
then there was that weird thing
afterwards and I've had I don't know
I don't know maybe I should've looked up
something to see if there was some bugs
or something but then there was this
there's this long period of who is like
took a few minutes to get through this
music not sure if it's like it I'm
pressing button oh look I type something
out baby Hearst deferred Ninh no this is
weird
no shove it up your bum nope okay take a
chill pill yo okay yeah nothing's going
on I'm gonna try one more time if it
just crashes the game again then I guess
that's it I
I guess I thought that was more story to
it I mean the intro gave the idea that
it was like a two-month period of time
because I said two months earlier and
that it was gonna be like some sort of
journey of redemption or something with
drug addiction I don't know I don't know
I'm I'm just utterly confused you look
at this jab it in your arm up like
breaking the game I know sure she'll go
now it's done now anything if this is
about to be like a credit sequence and
credits are supposed to be rolling then
something got messed up either way this
would be a very disappointing ending if
this was it the okay here's the level
change
and okay ah there's the weird white
stuff and let's not crash my game this
done
you're gonna be cool we gonna be cool
hope that's nope it just exits the game
I guess that's it so ah it was good for
a while there right up until the ending
I was I'm actually very disappointed by
that ending cuz there's nothing resolved
nothing happened so what am I to do
about that
anyway I'm gonna go look up online if
there's something else about it maybe I
can figure it out but for now that's it
so thank you all so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye